[Music]
[Applause]
chris mannix from sports illustrated
joins us on the program how do you think
this plays out with zion
yeah as far as this year we certainly
are trending in that direction the
latest news
about zion doesn't really give you
much reason to be optimistic he's going
to be back say before the all-star break
and
if you get past the all-star break and
the pelicans are still in a situation
where they are
at or near the bottom of the western
conference you start to wonder what's
the point i mean if you want to add more
talent around zion why not let him sit
out this entire year and you know add
something for next year but
longer term
is curious i mean it's not unprecedented
dan to
have a player with a long-term injury
work out away from a team that happens
uh in basketball and i'm sure in other
sports but
there's just there's always been kind of
this uh unease perhaps uh i don't know
how else would a phrase but some some
tenuousness between zion and the
pelicans so when you hear
he's going to be rehabbing in portland
oregon on the other side of the country
away from this team and the pelicans
quick to point out in that release he'll
be doing it under their medical
supervision you have to wonder kind of
what exactly is going on between these
two who plays first zion or ben simmons
i i still think ben simmons will get
moved
before the trade deadline if he's not
somehow some way he'll find his way back
into the philadelphia lineup now
you know there were some reports over
christmas about attraction between
simmons or the sixers and other teams
involving simmons
i haven't heard much of that lately the
sixers are still holding out for a
significant offer that includes
you know all-star level talents that can
help them this year and teams around the
league at least at this point are not
willing to offer it i think you're going
to see
um this go all the way up until the
february trade deadline because i don't
think the six are getting the kind of
offers
that they're looking for and they won't
get those kind of offers until we get
right up against that deadline
i was watching kyrie last night and i've
never had any doubts about his talent
you know i have doubts about some of the
things that he believes in but
here he is on display
and
he looked spectacular last night uh
what do you think the status is going to
be the rest of this season you know if
he's just a a road player and if you're
the nets do you want a fifth seed or a
sixth seed where you're playing more
road games in the playoffs than you
would if you're a top four seed
well as far as seeding goes and and i've
kind of had sort of casual conversation
people in brooklyn about that
that's not a variable i mean they
one of the responses i get is that who
says we can't win in six games like you
know they believe that these three guys
have enough talent for them you know not
to be forced into that seven game
situation and you look at it i mean
kyrie was brilliant as you said last
night 22 points shot better than 50
from the floor in his first game that
he's played competitively in
many months at this point and if you go
back to last season i mean the offensive
rating for kyrie james hard and kevin
durant in the 202 minutes they played
was about 119. in the playoffs that
number spiked to an absurd 130 in
limited minutes that they played
together in the postseason so they are
great
offensively together i i think look the
nets are going to keep him around
they're going to keep him in the
practice facility keep him going as a
part-time player because
they don't know i mean dan
by this time tomorrow would it surprise
you if kyrie just got vaccinated like
his his vaccination is gonna happen
without any fanfare he's probably gonna
walk into a walgreens and just get
vaccinated on a whim like so that you
know kyrie didn't dismiss that
possibility during his interviews last
night so that's out there also out there
is the possibility that the new york
city mayor the new mayor eric adams
could tweak this mandate now
this isn't an argument about vax or
anti-vax dan but the new york city
mandate is ridiculous the fact that
kyrie irving
can't play
but the three percent
of other nba players who are
unvaccinated can come into barclays
center and play is absurd so if i'm the
nets in addition to kind of crossing our
fingers and hoping james harden and
kevin durant can convince kyrie irving
to get vaccine or kyrie can do it on his
own
i'm kind of lobbying city hall and
saying look you know if you want to make
this vaccine mandate that's fine we
believe in public health too but make it
fair across the board if unvaccinated
players are coming in here who
presumably pose the exact same health
risk as kyrie irving they shouldn't be
allowed to play either
we're talking to chris mannix sports
illustrated nba senior writer klay
thompson coming back it looks like
they're uh pinpointing sunday
his addition means what for this team
this year
i mean
even if it's
75 80 percent of the klay thompson we're
used to it's enormous and you know when
i talk to people in and around golden
state
all you hear is how great he looks and
you know how patient they have been with
him kind of trying to work him back
to being as close to game shape as
possible now the things to watch for
with klay thompson earlier not gonna be
the three-point shot like he has been
working on that shot
you know he's been able to do that for
weeks and weeks if not months now
clay what made him a great all-around
player were two other fast to his game
one he was able to use the threat of the
three-point shot to ball fake get to the
basket pull up from mid-range does he
have
that same spring on that move to the
basket that's the first one and
defensively clay was a high level
defensive guy you know for most of his
years
and the uh warriors i think right now
top two in the nba and defensive
efficiency is he that same type of guy
if he's again 75 75-80 percent of what
he once was i mean they're basically
getting back an all-star-ish level
player if he's lost a little bit and
can't get that back at least not this
season that's something golden state
will have to adjust to i'm federally
mandated to ask you uh about lebron
james and the lakers
lebron's been playing great
but i i don't think he can play great
enough though your uh your assessment of
the lakers now we're into january
it's
you're hard-pressed to find
or to look for a pathway that sees them
making a deep run in the playoffs right
now um
you know the lakers are active out there
on the trademark i had one gm say to me
two nights ago is like you know why do
we keep hearing
about the type of players the lakers can
acquire for this
taylon horton tucker kendrick nunn first
round draft pick kind of poo-poo platter
that that is being sort of floated out
there
as as a possibility yeah horton tucker
is an appealing prospect but if you're
looking at
some of the top names that are out there
whether it's jeremy grant in detroit
maybe christian wood down in houston
those teams could have better offers uh
for the lakers i think for la
their only hope for
i guess salvation this season is if
anthony davis comes off this injury and
gets back to looking like the bubble
anthony davis we haven't seen that
player dan
in
you know over a year now i mean he was
pretty good last year and you can
certainly make the argument that if he
doesn't get hurt uh in the first round
lakers are in the finals last season but
he has not been the same player this
year his perimeter shooting has fallen
off a cliff look he's got to be their
full-time five and he has got to be a
highly effective full-time five deandre
jordan really doesn't have a lot left
dwight howard really doesn't have a lot
left i mean i know we're kind of getting
excited about this lebron james as a
five kind of
option but that's not gonna work long
term especially not when you go up
against bigger teams in the postseason
the lakers whenever anthony davis comes
back he has got to be a top five player
in the nba and i'm not sure based on
what i've seen this season that he has
that in it
great to talk to you again chris thanks
for joining us
not bad for the least valuable guest of
2021. you heard about that huh
i was set that clip by no fewer than
three people
but you're an award winner
is that like a razzy
kind of
kind of i uh and you know i didn't vote
i did not vote on the least valuable
guest but we love having you on
that's all right i've uh
i've now signed an exclusive deal with
maggie and perloff so well
you're leaving you're going to join
mcleven okay i am good luck with that
good luck with that this might be the
last time we see or hear from chris
mannix
ah he's so good
so bad that he's good i forgot all about
that that mannix was voted least
valuable guest
did we vote on that i think it was a
group decision it was and then the
listeners backed us to the hell of
course they did